good hairstylist is indispensable my guy
Shawn had him for 20 years we were
working together he's the reason I look
like a dapper little hunk boy and said
Oh raggedy dandy but one of the best
parts of getting your hair did isn't is
the hot Goss that happens who's dating
whom who's leaving whom who insists on
saying whom because it's grammatically
correct even though it sounds
pretentious and nothing shows this
chitchat off better than this adorable
viral video of a woman in her
hairdresser captioned salon talk you
crazy girl he kids it right girl I'm
trying to you I'm trying
come on powers just move right there
she's giving mommy and up to do so
comedians this mom didn't really ask her
hair dress or anything so is the next
client of this baby stylists get the
scoop on her life I'll say girl what's
new in your life solid food okay I see
you done girl what do you do to make
your ass look so fat oh you your pants
off